bonjour nicolas vidal bonjour j'espère
que vous allez bien et que vous êtes en
forme alors emmanuel macron qui décide
de prendre cette décision après que
angela merkel les prises
qu'en pensez vous n'en jetons plus
enfants qui est venue elle macron ça
c'est sûr alors si voilà une belle
preuve de suivisme lorsque l'allemagne a
décidé de suspendre le vaccin
astrazeneca est bien emmanuel macron
vous l'avez dit est monté rapidement au
pupitre depuis le montauban pour
annoncer la même chose branle bas de
combat et sur frenchies d'état major
rappelez-vous ce cher jean castex y
vanter les mérites et les vertus du
vaccin dimanche sur twitch et olivier
veyrat fier comme artaban qui n'y voyez
aucun problème lors de sa conférence de
presse hebdomadaire de jeudi dernier
mais depuis montauban dans ce beau
département du tarn
il a fallu faire une annonce improvisé
pour nous jouer les violons de la vision
commune européenne
mais en réalité emmanuel macron a fait
gribouiller une note en catastrophe pour
tenter de faire passer son suivisme pour
de la stratégie habilement tragique et
politiquement désastreux et
malheureusement ce suivisme envers
l'allemagne fait partie d'une longue
liste de petites et de grandes
soumission magali et pourtant nicolas le
couple franco-allemand on en parle
depuis de nombreuses années comme le
moteur de l'europe ce qui me chiffonne
c'est qu'apparemment l'allemagne ne sait
pas qu'elle est en couple avec la france
ou alors nos élites vivent un amour
funestement platonique et à sens unique
n'oubliez pas que tous les présidents
français depuis nicolas sarkozy sont une
génuflexion en allemagne le lendemain de
leur élection pour aller chercher leur
adoubement à berlin alors ça ressemble
de loin au baptême de clovis en 496 8 à
reims mais avec moins de panache en
réalité ils repartaient qu'une feuille
de route une accolade un bon point et
surtout un kinder car l'obsession nos
dirigeants c'est de donner des gages eu
d'excellentes de conduite à l'allemagne
et de sa peur tire toujours plus pour
lui plaire mais surtout aujourd'hui
c'est surtout sur les questions de
défense que les crispations sont de plus
en plus intense emmanuel macron lui il
est très précis le début de son
quinquennat d'échafauder une europe de
la défense en coopération mais
l'allemagne avec un petit côté vivent le
pire donc il serait bien entendu l'aide
de camp et il y actuellement 2
grands projets en route d'un côté vous
avez le char du futur et de l'autre le
système aérien du futur le fameux skaff
deux projets stratégiques devait
s'établir un apport équilibré entre les
deux nations de 50 50
chacun bien tu se partageant la maîtrise
d'ouvragé en fonction de ses spécialités
mais voilà qu'un gros caillou germanique
de monsieur qui tiennent à la claquette
française concernant les chars angela
merkel veut finalement deux tiers des
voûtes retombées industrielles suite à
l'arrivée d'une seconde entreprise
allemande dans la danse et pour le
système aérien le scaf la chancelière
elle de tout bonnement extorqué au
passage les brevets technologiques de
dassault qui depuis ne décolère
absolument pas ce projet concernait
aussi les drones et les patrouilleurs
avaient finalement pour ces derniers les
patrouilleurs les allemands et valeo
signé avec boeing exit la france sur le
plan de la france sur la pelouse de la
défense parlant deux autres infos savez
vous que les rangers
des militaires français fabriqué avant
dans le beau père igor nous viennent
d'allemagne et que le fameux famas de
fabrication française a été remplacé par
le hk 416 de construction je vous le
donne en mille allemande aussi alors
comme pour l'industrie la santé ou la
recherche la france avec emmanuel macron
continue à se dépouiller volontairement
de ses fleurons et l'allemagne est prête
à mettre en péril la réalisation de ces
projets européens pour ses propres
intérêts comme des romans elle l'a
toujours fait et pour démontrer enfin la
légende emmanuel macron angela merkel il
faut relire le discours de la sorbonne
en 2017
véritable oraison funèbre notre
souveraineté nationale qui a été
remplacé vous le savez pas la
souveraineté européenne et qui a relu ce
discours d' emmanuel macron un amant je
vous le donne aussi en mille ans d la
merkel
donc on pourrait également revenir se
traiter d'aix-la-chapelle en 2019 qui
pose bien des questions sur les
concessions de nos souveraineté au
profit de l'allemagne
enfin passons et pour finir et comme le
vaccin astrazeneca l'allemagne n'en ont
fait qu'à sa tête elle affermi
rappelez-vous et unilatéralement ses
frontières avec la france lors du
premier confinement est aujourd'hui
l'allemagne est bien la pause des tests
pcr sur sa frontière à la moselle aux
frontaliers français ce qui n'est pas le
cas dans le sens inverse
alors il nous reste quand même
l'espadrille heureusement nicolas vidal
mais est ce qu'il est possible selon
vous
rééquilibrer les rapports entre
l'allemagne et la france alors c'est
très compliqué pourquoi pour une raison
très très sain magali l'allemagne sera
européenne tant que l'europe sera
allemande l'allemagne se sert en réalité
l'union européenne 1 pour renforcer sa
souveraineté augmenter ses exportations
hors de l'union européenne affermir son
excédent commercial grâce à sa main
d'oeuvre très bon marché en europe de
l'est
sans oublier que dès le début où il
savait l'euro a été fondée sur le modèle
du mark allemand qui lui a énormément
servi
l'allemagne était aussi très souvent
aussi sommé la france d'appliquer des
réformes structurelles pour coller à
cette horde au libéralisme berlinois
sans compter que l'allemagne fait ami
ami avec les usa depuis très longtemps
et on comprend pourquoi
enfin l'allemagne fait primer sa
souveraineté et joue comme toujours sa
carte nationale
c'est son droit tel que l'a dit la cour
de karlsruhe où il ya quelques mois
finalement et pour terminer avec
emmanuel macron à la mandoline la france
continuera d'augmenter ne me quitte pas
et l'allemagne pourrait lui répondre à
son action guttural je suis venu te dire
que je m'en vais enfin il y en allemand
je suis méga lui merci en tout cas un
nicolas l'édito de la matinale de
nicolas vidal a retrouvé sur les réseaux
sociaux avant de vous retrouver jeudi
prochain